The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open Courseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT Open Courseware
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: OK.
So this is going to be a fun
lecture because it's mostly
pictures and language.
And it's also an area
of physical chemistry,
which is pretty much--
I mean, there's three
areas of physical chemistry
where people have trouble
talking to each other.
There's statistical mechanics.
There's quantum mechanics.
And there's the time dependent,
time independent forms
of quantum mechanics.
And these three
communities have to learn
how to talk to each other.
And I'm hoping that I will
help to bridge that gap.
OK.
So last time, we talked about
the time dependent Schrodinger
equation.
It's a simple
looking little thing.
Remember though, it's an
extra level of complexity
on what you already understand.
Now, in the special case
where the Hamiltonian is time
independent, then, if you
know all of the energy levels
and wave functions for the
time independent Hamiltonian,
you can immediately
write down the solution
to the time dependent
Hamiltonian.
And so you have a complete
set of wave functions.
And you have a complete
set of energy levels.
And with that, you can
basically describe something
that satisfies this thing.
Another set of coefficients
is often something
that you arrange for
simplicity or for insight.
And I want to understand--
I want to talk about that.
OK.
And so in the
previous lecture, we
talked about the probability
density, which is psi star psi.
And that can move.
And that can move in two ways.
In the wave function, if
there are two or more states
belonging to two or
more different energies,
then you can have motion.
And you can have motion like
breathing, where probability
moves towards the
extremes, or motion
where there is actually a wave
packet going from one side
to another.
So for anything
interesting to happen,
this probability
density has to include
at least two different
eigenstates belonging
to two different energy levels.
Now, the total probability
is just the integral
over all coordinates of
the probability density.
And probability is conserved.
So one of the things
that happens--
when you do an integral,
the wave functions go away.
And in this particular
case, integral psi star psi,
all you get is one.
Or you get a constant, depending
on how you normalize things.
But it's not time dependent.
Now, in understanding motion
from classical mechanics,
we know Newton's equations.
We know how the coordinate and
the momentum depend on time.
And so if we calculate
the expectation
value of the coordinate
or the expectation
value of the momentum,
we get some results.
And it turns out that these
things describe the motion
of the center of a wave packet.
A wave packet is anything that's
not just a single eigenstate,
so it moves.
And so the motion of
a single eigenstate--
the motion of a wave packet
is described by Newton's laws.
And this is Ehrenfest theorem.
And it can easily be proven.
But we're not going to prove it.
We're just going to use it.
So we are very interested
in expectation values
of the coordinate
and the momentum.
And for a harmonic
oscillator, this is duck soup.
Then we have nothing but
trivial integrals involving
the a's and a-daggers.
And so even though in some
ways the harmonic oscillator
is a more complicated problem
than the particle in a box,
the harmonic oscillator
is the problem
of choice for dealing with
motion and developing insight.
There's another useful--
OK.
We have this wave function here.
There is a huge amount of
information embedded in it,
too much to just look at.
We need to have ways of
reducing that information.
And one of the nice ways is
the survival probability.
The survival
probability tells you
how fast does the initial
state move away from itself.
And this is very revealing.
Another very revealing thing is
if this survival probability,
which is a function
of time and nothing
else, because we've integrated
over the wave functions--
if this survival
probability goes up and down
and up and down,
there are recurrences.
So at a maximum,
which is usually
a maximum at t equals 0
because the wave function is it
at its birthplace, the
survival probability
will start high and go down,
and come up, and go down.
And there's all sorts of
information about recurrences.
As the wave function
returns to its birthplace,
it might not return completely.
And so we get
partial recurrences.
And these tell us something.
And the times at which
the maxima in the survival
probability occur tell us
a lot about the potential.
And there are some
grand recurrences
where, because all of the
energy level differences
are an integer multiple
of a common factor,
then you get a
perfect recurrence.
And these are wonderful
for drawing pictures.
Now, you really want to
understand the concepts of time
dependent quantum
mechanics pictorially
and to develop a language
that describes it.
And there are a lot
of little pieces
here that you need to convince
yourself you understand
so you can use the language.
OK.
One of the things I said at
the beginning of the course
is the central object in quantum
mechanics is the wave function.
Or we could generalize to this.
This is actually the truth.
This is a partial truth.
This is everything that
we can possibly know.
But we can't know this.
We can never observe
the wave function.
However, we do observations.
And we construct
a picture, which
is what we call the
effective Hamiltonian.
This effective Hamiltonian
describes everything
we know, mostly energy levels.
We have formulas for
the energy levels.
And we determine the constants.
There's all sorts of stuff
that we collect by experiment.
And so we create an
object which we think
is like the true Hamiltonian.
And by having the
effective Hamiltonian,
we can get these things.
So we observe we make
some observations.
And then this is a reduced
version of the truth.
And we can get a pretty
good representation
of the thing that is
supposedly hidden from us.
OK.
So let's start
now at t equals 0.
At t equals 0, which I
like to call the pluck--
and it really makes it
contact with those of you who
are musicians, that
you know how to create
a particular kind of sound,
which will evolve in time.
And it depends on the details of
how you handle the instrument.
So at t equals 0,
we have this thing
which, if we have a complete
set of eigenfunctions
of the Hamiltonian, of the
time independent Hamiltonian,
we know we can write
this as cj psi j of x.
Now, often we don't need an
infinite number of terms.
But we know that there are lots
of different kinds of plucks.
And you can find out what
these coefficients are
by just calculating overlap
integral of these functions
with this initial state.
OK.
So this is telling you
what happens at t equals 0.
And if you can write
the initial state
as a superposition
of eigenstates,
then you can immediately
write the time
evolving object this way.
Now, we have a minus i.
Well, why do we need a minus i?
Well, because
we're going to take
the time derivative
of the Hamiltonian
and multiply it by iH bar.
We're going to want to get the
energy, not minus the energy.
And so we need a minus i here.
And we need a
divided by H bar here
in order to satisfy the
time independence or time
dependence.
So this always bothers people.
Why should there be an i here?
And why should it be minus i?
And I recommend not
trying to memorize it,
but to just convince yourself.
I need the minus i because I'm
going to bring down a minus i
over H bar times e.
And we have this iH bar.
The minus i times
i gives plus 1.
OK.
So now, in understanding how the
time dependent Hamiltonian can
be sampled, we build
the superposition states
with a minimum number of
terms, like two or three.
Even though, in order to create
a very, very sharply localized
state, it needs a huge
number of terms here.
But you always
build your insight
with something you
can do in your head.
And so for some problems,
you need only two states.
And for others, you need three.
And those are the
ones you want to kill.
You want to
understand everything
you can build with two and
three state superpositions.
OK.
So there's two
classes of problems.
OK so for a half
harmonic oscillator--
so for a half
harmonic oscillator,
we start with
harmonic oscillator
and divide it in half and
say this goes to infinity.
And so this side
is not accessible.
And so if the potential is
half of a harmonic oscillator
potential, then we
know immediately what
the eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions are.
They are the harmonic
oscillator functions
that have a node in the middle.
So we know that we have
v equals 1, v equals 3.
No v equals 0 or 2.
I mean, this corresponds
to the lowest level, v
equals 0 for the
half oscillator.
But this is
basically-- now, what
we're going to do is we
create some state of a half
oscillator.
And then we take
away the barrier.
So that's a cheap way of
creating localization.
Of course, we can't do
this experimentally.
But you could, in
principle, do it.
And so basically, you
want an initial state,
which is a superposition
of vibrational levels.
OK.
And this initial state
needs to have the wave
function be 0 at the barrier.
So since we're going to be
looking at the full potential,
we're taking away the barrier.
We're allowed to use
the even and odd states.
And so let's take the
three lowest states.
And so we have c0 psi 0
plus c1 psi 1 plus c2 psi 2.
OK.
This guy is OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you create the
states of the half harmonic
oscillator, do you
have to re-scale them
so that they normalize?
ROBERT FIELD: Yes.
We play fast and loose with
normalization constants.
We already always
know that, whenever
you want to calculate
anything, you're
going to divide by the
normalization integral.
However, it's OK.
Because we're going to be using
the full harmonic oscillator
functions, which
do exist over here.
And it's fine once we
remove the barrier.
But we want to choose a problem
which is as simple as possible.
OK, now, this guy is
not 0 at x equals 0.
And this guy is not
0 at x equals 0.
But you can say 0 is equal to c0
psi 0 of 0 plus c2 psi 2 of 0.
We choose the coefficients so
that these two guys together
make 0 at the boundary.
And why do we do this?
We're going to be calculating
expectation values of x and p.
And if we only have half
of the energy levels,
all of the intricacies
are going to be 0.
So we have to have
three consecutive levels
to have anything interesting.
OK, so the artifice
of making these two--
arranging the coefficients so
that you get a temporary node
at x equals 0--
it won't stay a node.
Because when we let things
oscillate with time,
these two will
oscillate differently.
And the node will go away.
But that's how you do it.
That's how you build
a superposition.
OK.
Now, what we want to do is
to be able to draw pictures
of what's happening and also
to calculate what's going on.
And one of the things
we use for our pictures
is the expectation value of x
and the expectation value of p.
So you know how to calculate
the expectation value of x.
We have this capital psi star
x capital psi star capital
psi integrate over x.
And so we get to c0 c1
x01 cosine omega t plus 2
c1 c2 x12 cosine omega t.
Now, how did I do that?
Oh, come on.
You can do it, too.
So what is this x01?
Well, x01 is the integral
psi 0 star x psi 1 dx.
And we know we can replace
x by a plus a-dagger
times the constant.
We always like to
forget that concept.
We only bring it in
at the end anyway.
And so, well, this has a value--
it's a constant, the constant
that we're forgetting--
times 1 square root, right?
And x12 is the
same sort of thing.
It's going to be the same
constant times 2 square root.
This is easy.
So getting from
this symbol to this,
that just requires
a little practice,
and then simplifying
further to know
what these x's are, and then
the constraints on c2 and c0.
We have all that stuff.
OK.
And now, we can draw a picture
of what's going to happen.
So here we have the
full oscillator.
And let's just draw
some energy which is--
now that's complicated.
We have a time
dependent wave function,
which is composed of several
different energy eigenstates.
So what is its energy?
Well, you can evaluate
what the energy
is by taking the expectation
value of the Hamiltonian.
And so you can do that.
So what we've made
at t equals 0 is
something that looks like this.
It's localized on the left side.
Or it's more localized
on the left side.
Now, sometimes, you're
going to worry about phase.
And so many times when
you're working symbolically
rather than actually
evaluating integrals,
there are symbolic phase
choices that what you're using
has made.
And for example, for
the harmonic oscillator,
if you look in the
book, you'll see
that, for all of the harmonic
oscillator functions,
the outer lobe is
always positive.
And the inner lobe
is alternating
with the quantum number.
So that's a phase convention
that's implicit in everything
that people have derived.
And as long as the
different things
you combine in doing
a calculation involve
the same phase convention,
which is implicit-- we don't
want to look at what functions.
We want to look at these xij's.
OK.
And so those things
that we're manipulating
have a phase implicit
in how you define them.
But that's gone in
your manipulation.
So you want to be
a little careful.
OK.
So we start out and
the expectation value
is on this side.
And the psi star psi is
localized on this side mostly.
And at a later time--
so this is a later time.
I shouldn't make it bigger.
At a later time, this thing
has moved to the other turning
point.
Back and forth, back and forth.
Now, since we have
three energy levels--
and well, actually, we
have a coherence term
which involves the
product of psi 0 and psi 1
and psi 1 and psi 2--
they differ in
energy both by omega.
So these two things have the
same oscillation frequency.
And so what's going to happen
is the wave function, the wave
packet, is going to move
from this side to that side,
back and forth always forever
at the same frequency,
no dephasing.
In the middle, I can't tell you
what it's going to look like.
I don't want to tell you.
Because you don't care.
You care mostly about what's it
going to look like at a turning
point.
Or what is it going to look like
when it returns to home base?
And all sorts of
insights come from that.
OK.
Now, I said, well, if we want
to know the energy of this wave
packet, well, we take
the expectation value
of the Hamiltonian.
And the expectation
of the Hamiltonian
is c0 squared e0 plus c1
squared e1 plus c2 squared e2.
These things are
easy once you've gone
through it a couple of times.
Because what's happening
is you have these factors,
e to the minus i
ej t over H bar.
And they cancel when
you do a psi star psi.
Or they generate a
difference, omega H bar omega,
when you have different
values of the energy.
So this is something that you
can derive really quickly.
And the fact that
your eigenfunction--
the psi's in your
linear combination
up there are eigenfunctions
of the Hamiltonian.
So every time the Hamiltonian
operates in a wave function,
it gives the energy
times that wave function.
And then you're taking
the expectation value.
And so we have the wave
function time itself integrated.
And that goes away.
So after doing this
a few times, you
don't need to write
the intermediate steps.
And you shouldn't.
Because you'll get lost
in the forest of notation.
Because one of the
things you probably
noticed in the last lecture is
the equations got really big.
And then we calculate
something else.
And it gets twice as big.
And then all of a
sudden, it all goes away.
And that's what you want
to be able to anticipate.
OK.
So you can really kill this
half oscillator problem.
There's nothing much
happening except you
create a localization.
And when you take
away the other--
when you restore
the full oscillator,
everything oscillates at omega.
And so you have a
whole bunch of terms
contributing to the
motion of the wave packet.
And they're all very simple.
Because they're all oscillating
at the same frequency.
Now, as an aside, I want to say
there's a huge number of stuff
that's up in this lecture
that's going to be
on the exam, a huge amount.
So if for example you wanted
to calculate something
like x squared, well, fine.
You know what the selection
rule for x squared is.
It's delta v of 0
plus or minus 2.
And so this thing is going to
generate some constant terms
and some terms at 2 omega.
OK.
So there are a lot of things
about the harmonic oscillator
that make it really wonderful
to consider a problem, even
a complicated problem,
which is not explicitly
a harmonic oscillator problem.
Because you can get everything
so quickly without any
thought after a little
bit of investment.
OK.
Now, we haven't talked
about electronic transitions
and potential energy curves.
But we will.
And I think you know about them.
And so we have some
electronic ground state.
And we have some
electronically excited state.
And so each of these states
has a vibrational coordinate.
And we can pretend that it's
harmonic even if it's not.
Because we build a
framework treating
them as harmonic,
and then discover
that there's discrepancies
which we can fit to a model.
And we can determine
from the time
dependence what that model is.
OK.
So we start out with a
molecule in v equals 0.
And there is a much
repeated truism.
Electrons move
fast, nuclei slow.
Transition is instantaneous,
or nearly instantaneous,
because it involves
the electrons.
So what ends up happening
is you draw a vertical line.
And now, you transfer this wave
function to the upper state.
You just move-- this is
the probability amplitude
distribution of the vibration.
We transfer that to
the excited state.
And that's not an eigenstate,
It's a localized state,
localized at a turning point.
Now, you want to know--
so there's the
Franck-Condon principle,
that is just another
way of saying electrons
move fast, nuclei slow.
And there is delta x
equals 0 delta p equals 0.
If the nuclear state can't
change while the electron is
jumping, then the coordinate and
the momentum are both constant.
So you're creating
a wave packet.
And the best place to create
it is near a turning point.
Because then, you can match
the momentum of this guy
to that zero point momentum,
which you can calculate.
You know how to calculate this.
Because the potential energy
curve is 1/2 k x squared.
And the momentum is given by
this energy difference here.
And so you can work it out.
It's in the notes.
I don't want to write it down.
So you're going to
create something
which is vertical and
is not quite exactly
at the turning point.
Because you have to have
a little bit of momentum
to match the zero
point momentum here.
So you know everything
about the initial state.
And so you can calculate what
it is by taking the overlap of v
equals 0 of the
ground state with all
of the vibrational levels
of the excited state.
And so we have the
coefficients of each
of those vibrational levels
in the excited state that
makes this wave packet.
Now, of course,
this wave packet is
going to move back and
forth, back and forth.
And if this were a
harmonic oscillator,
it would move harmonically.
And so the only thing
that would appear
in the expectation
value of x is going
to be this motion at omega.
Now, this is usually
a relatively high
vibrational level.
And the molecule is not
being harmonic here.
So there are correction terms
called anharmonicity terms.
So we have the energy level
expression plus H bar omega e
xe--
that's one number--
plus 1/2 squared.
So we have a linear term
and a quadratic term.
And this omega e xe is on
the order of 0.02 times omega
e, 2%.
So it's a small thing.
But if you're going
to be allowing a wave
packet to be built out of
many vibrational levels,
this guy is going to
de-phase a little bit.
So you go around and come back.
And you can't quite
have everybody
back where they started.
And so you'll see a
decreasing amplitude here.
And that's best looked at
by the survival probability.
And you'll see characteristic
behavior in the survival
probably.
OK.
But let's go a little
bit deeper before I
move on to-- what time is it?
Oh, I'm doing OK.
So let's just say
our superposition
state, the electronically
excited state,
is a combination of v
equals 10 and v equals 11.
So we know immediately
that psi star t psi t--
this probability amplitude--
probability, yes,
this probability is
c10 squared psi 10
squared plus c11 squared psi
11 squared plus 2 c10 c11
psi 10 psi 11 cosine omega t.
That's not very legible.
Now, I'm playing
fast and loose here.
Because I've done this before.
I know what disappears.
And I know, if it's
harmonic, you just get this.
Well, if there's two
states, this thing
is really just the
frequency associated
with these two levels.
OK.
Now, once we have this, we
can also generate the survival
probability.
Well, the survival
probability, capital P
of t, that's defined as the
square modulus of psi star xt
psi x0 dx.
OK.
And you can immediately write
what that is going to be.
It's going to be c10 squared.
And we've integrated so
the wave functions go away.
And so we have c10 e to
the i H bar 10.5 omega
t divided by H bar plus c11
squared e to the minus i plus H
bar 11.5 omega e over H bar.
OK.
Why did I made the mistake here?
Well, we have a psi star.
And so we're going to get
the complex conjugate of e
to the minus i omega.
So you end up getting this.
Practice that.
AUDIENCE: That whole
thing is [? the ?]
modulus squared, right?
ROBERT FIELD: Yes.
I have that right.
Exactly.
So and now, lo and behold, we
know what to do with this too.
And so we're going to get
c1 0 to the 4 plus c--
not 1-0, 10, c11
to the 4 plus 2 c10
squared c11 squared
cosine omega t.
Isn't that neat?
So we've got a whole
bunch of constant terms.
This is constant.
Because it's square modulus
and it's to the fourth power.
And so all of these
coefficients are positive.
At t equals 0, this is 1.
And so at t equals 0,
the survival probability
is at a maximum.
And at some later time,
that survival probability
will be at a minimum.
OK.
And so you can say the maximum
will occur at integer when
omega t is equal to 2 n pi.
So then the exponential
factor is always 1.
And we have a minimum when omega
t is an odd multiple of pi.
And all the exponential
factors are minus 1.
So we can also now
look at the expectation
value for x of t and p of t.
And I'm going to
just draw sketches.
So for x of t, we have
something that looks like this.
This is at the
left turning point.
This is the right turning
point, or near the right
turning point.
And this is at pi over 2 omega.
This is at pi over omega.
So that's the half
oscillator point.
Now, it starts out and
the expectation value
is at the left turning point.
And it's not changing.
The derivative of
the expectation value
with respect to t is 0.
The momentum, which
has a different phase--
the momentum starts
out at 0 also.
And at pi over 2 omega,
it reaches a maximum.
And at pi over omega,
it reaches 9 again.
But the important
thing here is at t
equals 0 the derivative
of the momentum
is as big as it can get.
So what's that telling you?
It's telling you
this wave packet,
as far as coordinate space is
concerned, it's not moving at t
equals 0.
As far as momentum is concerned,
it's moving like crazy.
And so this survival probability
is changing entirely dominated
by the change in momentum,
which is encoded in the wave
function, which is neat.
Because Newton's equation
says that the time derivative
of the momentum is equal to--
that's the mass
times acceleration--
is equal to the
force, which is minus
the gradient of the potential--
the function of time.
And for a harmonic oscillator,
the gradient potential is x kx.
And so it's telling you that
we have this relationship
between x and t and p.
And we know what
the momentum is.
And I'm sorry.
And so the change
in the momentum,
which is responsible for
the change in the survival
probability at t equals
0, is due to the gradient
of the potential.
So we're actually
sampling what is
the gradient of the potential
at the left turning point.
And often, for any
kind of a problem,
we want to know
what kind of force
is acting on the wave packet.
There it is, classic mechanics
embedded in quantum mechanics.
It's really amazing.
So if you have some
way of measuring
the survival probability
near t equals 0,
it's telling you what the
slope of the potential
is at the turning point.
OK.
Well, if we have an
initial state which
involves many eigenstates,
the Hamiltonian,
we still know that there's going
to be some complicated behavior
which is modulated by omega.
So we have a cosine
omega t always.
And so no matter
what kind of a wave
function we make, if we start
out at one turning point,
it's going to go to the
other turning point.
And it'll keep coming
back, and back, and back.
And so one could imagine
doing an experiment where--
let's just draw the excited
state and some other repulsive
state.
So at this turning point,
vertical transition
to that repulsive state is
within the range of your laser.
And at this turning
point, it's way high.
And so what you
can imagine doing
is probing where this wave
packet is as a function of time
by having a probe pulse which
creates dissociating fragments.
And now, that is what
Ahmed Zewail did.
He talked about real
dynamics in real time.
So when the wave packet is
here, it can't be dissociated.
When it's here, it can.
And you look at the fragments.
Very simple.
So there are lots of ways of
taking these simple pictures
of wave packets
moving and saying,
OK, I can use them to set
up an experiment where
I ask a very specific question.
And I get answers.
And I know what to
do with the answers.
Now, if it's not
harmonic, you can still
do Zewail's experiment
or some other experiment.
And you can ask, OK, the
wave packet moved over here.
And there's some
dynamics that occurs.
It dissociates or
you do something.
And when it comes back, it's
not at the same amplitude.
And so you can use the time
history of these recurrences
if it's harmonic.
If it's not harmonic, then the
recurrences-- even if nothing
happens over here,
the recurrences
will be increasingly
less perfect.
And so you measure
the anharmonicity.
OK.
Five minutes.
Tunneling is a quantum
mechanical phenomenon.
And again, you want to use
the simplest possible picture
to understand the
signature of tunneling.
And so what do you do?
Well, the simplest
thing you can do
is start with a
harmonic oscillator.
The next thing you do is you
put a barrier in the middle.
And you make it really thin.
Thin is because you don't want
to calculate the integral.
You want to just say, oh yeah,
I know that the wave function--
forget about the barrier.
We know the magnitude of the
wave function at the barrier,
OK?
And so if you have a state
which has a maximum here,
well, that means that
it's feeling the barrier.
And so you know what to do.
If there is a node here, it
doesn't know about the barrier.
So you can do all sorts
of things really fast.
OK.
So and it's harmonic because
you're going to want to use
a's and a-dagger's.
So v equals 1, 3, 5.
They have nodes here.
They don't know
about the barrier.
Or if they do, it's
a very modest effect.
If you make this thin enough,
you won't know about it all.
And then v equals 0,
2, 2 4, et cetera--
well, they're maxima.
Well, they have a
local maximum here.
And remember, this is
a harmonic oscillator.
So the big lobes
are on the extremes.
The smallest lobe is in
the middle, but it's not 0.
OK.
There are also
symmetry restrictions.
This is a problem
that has symmetry.
We have even functions
and odd functions.
And for the even functions,
d psi dx is equal to 0.
And for the odd functions,
psi of 0 is equal to 0.
OK.
So this is something that-- you
choose the simplest problem.
And you use symmetry.
And bang, all of a sudden,
you get fantastic insights.
So let's look at what happens
to the even functions.
So let's just draw a picture of
the harmonic oscillator energy
levels.
And we have a barrier, which
we say maybe goes that high.
And so we have 1.
And we have 3.
And we have 5.
They're basically not
affected by the barrier.
Because they have a
node at the barrier.
And then we have v equals 0.
What happens to v equals 0?
Well, it hits this barrier.
And it's got a large amplitude.
And it can't accrue more phase
as you go through the barrier.
So when it hits the
other turning point,
it doesn't satisfy the
boundary conditions.
It'll go to infinity at x
equals positive infinity.
So it has to be shifted so
that the boundary conditions
at the turning points are met.
And the only way
that can happen is
it gets shifted up
in energy a lot.
So v equals 0 is here.
Now, it can't be shifted
above v equals 1.
Because that would
violate the node rule.
And if you draw a picture
of the wave function for v
equals 0 in the boundary
region, the wave function
has to look something--
well, it has
to look something like that.
So we have two lobes.
And it's trying to make
a node, but it can't.
It's a decreasing exponential.
I mean, if you have a wave
going into this region
of the barrier, you can have
an increasing exponential
or a decreasing exponential.
You can never satisfy
continuity of the wave function
with the increasing exponential.
But you can with the
decreasing exponential.
And so the height of the barrier
determines how close this guy
comes to having a node.
It never will.
And how does this compare to the
wave function for v equals 1?
Well, the wave function for
v equals 1 looks like this.
The amplitude in this lobe
and the amplitude in that lobe
are the same.
But the sign is reversed.
And so basically,
this picture tells you
that these two levels have
almost exactly the same energy.
So v equals 0 is shifted up.
v equals 2 is shifted up,
but not quite so much.
And v 4 is shifted
up hardly at all.
And so you get what's
called level staggering.
And this level staggering is
the signature of tunneling.
This is how we know about
tunneling, the only way we
know about tunneling.
So we measure the energy levels.
And it tells us how are
the wave functions sampling
this barrier.
Now, this is a childish barrier.
And there is a real barrier--
molecules isomerize.
And they isomerize
over a barrier.
And the barrier isn't
necessarily at x equals 0.
But if you understand
this problem,
you can deal with isomerization.
Now, I'm an author
of a paper that's
just appearing in Science
in the next few weeks
on the isomerization from
vinylidene to acetylene.
There's a barrier involved.
So these sorts of pictures are
important for understanding
those sorts of phenomena.
Now, so I'm done really.
So what we are now
encountering with the time
dependent Schrodinger
equation is discovering
how dynamics, like
tunneling, is encoded
in an eigenstate spectrum.
Because the encoding is
level staggering eigenstates.
So people normally
have this naive idea
that eigenstate time independent
Hamiltonian spectroscopy
does not sample dynamics
because it's only
measuring energy levels.
Real dynamical processes
are time dependent.
But the dynamics is encoded
in energy level patterns.
And that is actually
my signature
in experimental spectroscopy.
I've looked for ways
in which dynamics is
encoded in eigenstate spectra.
And chemists are interested
in dynamics much more than
in structure.
So that's it for today.
I will see you on Wednesday.